[Music]
celebrating cameroon's youth with the
parade for its aging leader they marched
the portrait of their 87 year old
President Paul Biya who by the time he
leaves power will be in his mid 90s
making him the oldest living state
leader that's if he's able to finish his
time in office because in the country's
english-speaking region young people are
taking up arms joining a separatist
movement they want to break away from
Cameroon to create their own country
Amazonia home to 4 million people in the
size of Switzerland the english-speaking
regions are on lockdown since Sunday's
local elections violence there has
killed 3,000 people and left a million
displaced most of them children in a
rare public address BIA called on young
people to lay down their arms calling
for dialogue going once again I urged
them to come out of the bush and rejoin
the other fellow young citizens while
leading normal lives in our society
this is rapper about Sarah who was
arrested in an opposition rally and his
music he's an outspoken critic of the
government calling on the President to
work for the people not against them and
accusing the aging elite of leaving the
young and their aspirations behind
hopeful the government says people here
are free to express themselves but when
it comes to President Paul Biya or the
english-speaking regions it's another
matter
and so anti-terror laws are being used
to arrest people who are critical of the
government and say young people are
having to use other ways to express
themselves portrait in maths it's come
on Bernard a take away is originally
from the english-speaking regions his
exhibition the hard way the only way is
about his personal struggles but also
the need for peace among the Cameroonian
people I'm not happy of the situation
but they see me as a 9 I mean a dying
policeman's are dying animals are dying
so it's not really good so I'm really
feeling bad because that is where I came
from
for French speaking our decision on that
week good day art can do what politics
cannot and awake the masses yeah it's
only unification so art is the mirror of
society and the issue here is that we
have not successfully United the English
and French Cameroon it is something that
can be easily resolved with a little
world power
artists one vision painting a nation
struggling to find unity where a young
majority feels silenced and disconnected
from its old leaders now wanting to take
control of their own future
Nikolas honk al-jazeera Dwolla